tutti sono oggi nuovissima challenge
indovinate chi infatti siamo uno di
fronte all'altro però questo indovina
chi è super speciale perchè abbiamo i
personaggi horror i personaggi dei
videogiochi personaggi cattivi tutti i
vostri personaggi preferiti ci sono
tutti personaggi dunque fatto trovando
vinix live
ma anche di tutti i personaggi che voi
adorate i vostri preferiti divertente
miracolosa adesso c'è un bel mi piace
in questo video raggiunge quindi simile
anche se faremo una seconda parte
aggiungeremo i personaggi che voi ci
consigliere che congiu nei commenti
quindi iscrivetevi tutti ma prima vi
facciamo vedere esattamente che
personaggi
abbiamo poi vi spieghiamo velocemente il
gioco ma penso che già lo conoscete
indovina chi allora iniziamo dall ultimo
banco l'ultima fila abbiamo ma l'etica
mister bit baldi il lupo cattivo
il nonno di gremi dracula poi abbiamo
scheletri night i pennywise che sarebbe
quello degli anni 90 quello vecchio
perché l'attenzione poi abbiamo anche
quello lungo poi abbiamo ovviamente g
el'arrivo il grinch blender me
ricordiamo è lei nun panna tel
la moglie di chucky che mi sembra che si
chiami tiffany it pennywise questo è
quello nuovo dal 2017 scrivete nei
commenti quale più inquietante dei due e
poi rivenderli come di qual è il vostro
personaggio preferito tra tutti quelli
che nominerò adesso sono in in umiltà lo
slimer di ghostbusters joker
freddi di file knights ferry voldemort
samara sa chi è il gelataio killer
cattivo quindi questi sono tutti i
nostri personaggi in italia ovviamente
agli eccessi
noi dovremo scegliere un personaggio che
poi lascia questo no dovrà indovinare le
cui faremo delle domande a testa e
dovremo abbassare le case di linee ad
esempio io chiedero a il naso se evita
le dice di no
molto probabilmente potrebbe essere pose
molto seguita e mi dice sia il naso
allora sicuramente abbasserò la
casellina di voldemort dello slider è in
forma tutti gli altri che non hanno il
naso ok mettetevi comodi prendete i
pochi bel mi piace e inizia subito ora
adesso io mi giro dall'altra parte mita
però gli occhi perché vitale sceglierà
il personaggio non lo dira voce alta
ovviamente sono io sento ma ve lo
indicherà così voi saprete che
personaggio è poi io farò lo stesso
andora e premio di personaggio c non so
quale scegliere vediamo vediamo
citiamo quale mi consigliate
ok io penso di scegliere eccola si è
scelto ok dove scelto no cantinati e
chiudi gli occhi o immaginati di più
sono molto indeciso
vorrei chimico si consiglia poi di
scegliere allora scelgo ok la prima
domanda è allora io chiedo se questo
personaggio ai capelli
penso di sì nessuno ti correggete
partita ma penso di sì sì sì ai capelli
ai capelli
quindi dobbiamo togliere tutti quelli
che non hanno i capelli
allora questa cela i capelli questa sera
questo ce l'ha questo tu non ce l'ha
qui e baldi c'è larino pelli ha sì è
vero tuffo
valli a un vino di fare solo ce li hai
capelli che era slide renderman
splendere non ce li ami quindi quindi
via nonno primi in sicilia i capelli
misereor coeli ha un po no no no grilli
non ce li ha allora via poi questi ce li
hanno questo non c'è la volte molto non
ce l'hai capelli
via taglio mi sa che c'ha un ciuffetto
sopra ma secondo me non ce li hai
capelli questo che lo slime è neanche ai
capelli quindi l il manager e ai capelli
si basta questi cederanno tutti credimi
che c'e nei capelli
eliminate un bel po di personaggi sei
già avvantaggiato ovviamente vince
indovino per primo il personaggio allora
tocca a me fare una domanda da sabato di
chi ha la pelle si maledizione allora
eliminiamo freddi perché ha il pelo con
l
eliminiamo il gelataio perché hai fatto
tutelato eliminiamo c'è anche perché
fateli classica lo slime è fatto di
james passa solo non so di che cosa si è
fatto
penso di plastica perché una bambola
eliminiamo la moglie dice eliminiamo
annabelle perché di plastica lo slider
me non ho idea di che cavolo sia fatto
però forse alla pelle
forse alla pelle con in ottica fattivi e
smi andrina per questa categoria il lupo
è fatto di per sé baldino lo so ma di
cosa hai fatto perché non lo so va beh
lo lascio per gli altri hanno la pelle
ok però abbiamo eliminato un bel po che
tocca a te che domanda vuoi farmi allora
vediamo domanda può farti posso
chiederti per caso se il personaggio dai
capelli color rosso
no noi mai capelli color rossi quindi
non lo so comunque togliamo via penny
wise e wise poi altri doveri rossi sono
it di wight scuole recente giochi che è
che per i rossi hanno ben dove c'è
capelli biondi primo anno non so perché
sta ancora lì comunque concordo
allora la mia domanda è ray ai capelli
neri no e allora togliamo samare che ai
capelli neri poi evin
immagino che i capelli neri poi slant
urina e capelli neri che forse dracula
con i capelli neri ok ecco fatto aspetta
malefica di che collega i capelli non
sono sicura penso che abbia i capelli
neri schizzi ai cappellini magnetica che
rimane credo un po che se ne dite
è un animale
no non è un animale quindi togliamo il
lupo
togliamo il grinch che a me allora la
mia domanda è è un videogioco oltre che
non lo so
[Musica]
allora credo abbiano fatto anche il
videogioco però non è un videogioco non
è un videogioco che allora sogniamo e lo
nego granny il nonno baldi e mister mix
bene di vendere molti pochi allora la
domanda è un uomo
no no quindi una donna quindi pdl nei
board di appalti di afragola solenne saw
l'enigmista è un uomo si e poi mandando
ben moglie di ciechi e via joker anche
perché molto bene quindi anche io mi
avvicino allora allora fare una domanda
per vedere
uno di questi ai capelli rossi no ok
tradiamo sia it moderno kate vecchio è
rimasto l'altro la mia domanda è questo
personaggio è bionda
no non è pronto quindi come si dice chi
vi ama bello mi sembra castana tiro
mettono potrebbe essere anche la usa
pezzo di riuscendo minare con questa
domanda quindi l'asta indovinando quindi
anche una madre ai capelli si è arrivati
dovendo virale però secondo me tu hai
scelto g e g e tu che avevi scelto
ed è tutto più divertente martina
un'altra partita e poi non saprete ok
allora questa volta voi saprete cosa ha
scelto vitale ma non saprete cosa ho
scelto io così assieme a lui dovrete
indovinare
vediamo vediamo vediamo
credo misamis a mi sa che andremo a
scegliere proprio ok
certo abbiamo scelto loro ora girati
anche voi giratevi perché non dovete
vedere con la prego io ok vediamo kit
kat apa religiosa su carta forbice sasso
allora prima domanda è il rossetto ha il
rossetto normale il rossetto ok ora devo
togliere tutti quelli con il rossetto
quindi d'autore di ips devo togliere so
perché sono un aspetto la moglie di ciò
che hanno averne un rossetto non capisco
se non sembra che merita e rose ma che
mimano stretto l'altro it e dracula il
rispetto mi summit è sporco di sangue e
malefica
il rossetto anche baldi e rosse perché
già scritta quante persone credo che
gioca nel rossetto mi ero dimenticata la
mia domanda adesso è è un personaggio
maschile si ok
cominciamo ad eliminare due anni
magnetica la ndrina samara la scritta da
lontano john che è bene uguali si
finisse amara da moglie di sacchi
annabelle in anno
bene lo aspettavo di più bello da non
male toccate adesso allora la mia
domanda e non sono sicura che domanda
alla carnagione di colore rosa allora
tagliamo reddito diamo voglia morte
perché bianco samara invece emerge il
gelataio e bianco slimer avrebbe invece
bianchissima treni e che pure potrebbe
essere considerata anche rosa con la
legge e lo nei vorrei abbastanza rosa
aperte
bianco di starmi terroso il lupo e il
nonno
vabbè il nonno lasciamolo perché
potrebbe essere rosa domanda è il
personaggio che c'è che hai scelto alla
carnagione bianca
sì sì ok allora dobbiamo sassi lo slider
e freddi e il lupo nonno baldi non ha la
carnagione bianca mister nico non ha la
carnagione bianca di trincee non ha la
carnagione bianca e lo neighbor non esca
pantone bianca un ok
piano piano ci stiamo ci stiamo muovendo
pochettino il cui valore avete anche
domanda città 3 facendo questi per sanzi
allora è vecchio e no non è vecchio ok
allora tagliamo grammy e togliamo il
nonno ne rimangono tre
vuoi provare ad indovinare la tirasse la
possibilità per mandare allora la mia
domanda adesso vediamo ai capelli rossi
si domandò nomi di al joker via volta
via su via serata di dorina flander man
di afragola e guardate un po chi rimane
quindi sono solo 2 contro 3 a provare ad
indovinare
sì voglio provare ad indovinare figura
frate sbagli hai perso davvero me tu hai
scelto
sono tutti a due hit quindi e secondo me
tu hai scelto non penny wise degli anni
90 mai hai scelto penny wise moderno si
pensi che allora secondo me tu hai
scelto mister mit
no ho sbagliato io ero allora è l'unico
o acciacchi silvio lo sai chi ti sento
mister mitko perché quando ho detto a il
rossetto tu hai subito dal giornalista
io l'ho fatto apposta fatto di restart
anche berlino è coinvolto ma che fai
albergo bene finiamola challenge concia
chi è viva ed è stato divertente come se
volete giocare i bambini 0
lasciate un bel mi piace consiglio a
pezzi gli altri personaggi sono i
commenti o se volete possiamo ottenere
questi e cambiare un po le dinamiche del
giorno mesi la tesi tutto il mei con me
magari le domande le domande possiamo
fare quattro piazze giri su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite le previsioni
[Musica]
anche il cuore divertente
queste materie non mancano mai
[Musica]